Hey, how's it going, bros?
My name is PewDiePie!
You can hold your celebrations. I'm not going away forever,
just yet.
I'm just going away for another trip, and I've decided, not to upload during this time.
Because my hair is just so god-damn awful.
I'm looks like Demitri trying sell sweatpants.
Usually when I go away, I prepare videos in advance.
it's a lot of work,
but we make it happen. But this time, it just felt…forced
I don't want to put…
quantity over quality.
Never thought I'd say that.
I feel so weird.
I feel so…ugh.
Quantity wins on YouTube. That's…
like no question.
Look at Leafy Is Here, okay?
[Quiet chuckle]
I'm kidding, Calvin. (Leafy's real name)
[blows kiss twice]
Last year when I prepared for scare PewPiePie, I made so many videos in advance, because I knew I was gonna be away for a month.
And…I really hated that,
because…
I made videos that I didn't like…
because I had to make them,
and…
just…wasn't fun.
And now I feel finally really happy about the content that I'm making, and I want to stay true to that. So, no more shit content!
That's the funniest joke of this video. I haven't taken a break like this from YouTube in probably two years. So it's a little scary,
and you don't know what's gonna happen, but we're just gonna have to go with it.
If you will…if…please be back cause I will be back as well.
Thank you!
I love you guys so much!
I hope you guys understand this decision.
[Turn around and hit microphone]
It's just the way the…
It's gonna go from…thank you for understanding this decision.
The feedback I've been getting lately on the channel has just been…
fucking amazing! (hell yeah it has)
And I wanna keep that up, and I think this is the best way to do it.
So I'll see you in *seven days*
[echoes in asterisks]
Have a great time until then, and remember bros:
[Kisses fist] Stay awesome!
Translator: Cristina Martinez-Saneaux, Ian Golden, Ehm, PurpleDolphin19, Mustafa Shakir,
Corrector: Hans Rega
I want a K-Pop haircut, but I got sleazy Russian, instead.
[Russian accent]
You want to buy sweatpants?